[Music]
red light
loud and clear jared cavall frank
penelope if i'm getting that right alex
nick
all right hey everybody how many people
do we have here 101 i think that means
we have enough people
to get started with this thing that's
actually a good number so
i am clicking record
on my
first backup which is a sure mv88
plugged into an iphone
with the sure motive recording then i
have my second backup
on quicktime audio and then i have my
primary this atr 2100 or actually a
newer version from audio technica usb
all in all i mean this is three forms of
backup just to give you an idea of how
cheap this podcasting game can be this
is probably 120 bucks maybe 200 worth of
gear total and then we have youtube for
free thanks youtube thanks google
and i'm excited to dive in so we will go
back and forth
between
live questions
we have 135 people 138 this will
probably continue to grow
and some questions that were submitted
beforehand so i will go back and forth
between those and just to give folks a
few minutes to pop in because it's 301
pm start time of three
actually
i'm going to reverse the order
and see if i can answer a few things
in the chat so please fire away feel
free
to drop in some questions
and
i will answer a handful of those and
then we'll jump to the pre-submitted and
we will
continue along those lines barik i think
you said one is none that's a reference
to the two is one and one is none so if
you have two of something you will lose
one and you will have one remaining if
you only have one you will end up with
none and that is from my friends in the
military
feels weird to hear tim in one time
speed florian i know
may i haunt your dreams just a little
bit less
after this hello from ireland connor
great
strong irish name
nice to
meet you
and
let's
continue
down with the questions and then i will
edit this to make it sound pristine
or my team will
hello from quito yes patricia let's see
do i still invest in startups i very
rarely this is from bogdan invest in
stars but i do occasionally invest in
startups at the moment it is mostly
going to be
climate solution tech related
or
web 3 although i've really dialed back
on that to reallocate to more of the
climate solutions and
next generation agriculture things along
those lines
okay
let's see
looking
i haven't done a live chat in a long
time so it'll take me a minute to get
accustomed to navigating the chat box
it's been a long time
all right
this is from chris i've produced tedx
chicago for the past four years i've
often wondered if you'd consider doing
tim talks live events with you
interviewing folks you'd like to talk to
thoughts reaction so chris actually
just prior to covid this would have been
wow
q4 of 2019 so end of 2019 and then
potentially january of 2020 i was in
discussions with multiple venues
in austin to do a live podcast series
that would be something
similar to
the
series that you might see on say netflix
with some of the late night show hosts
and
i consider doing that i'm still
considering doing it it's really just a
question of logistics time
and
life energy which we may come back to so
that is still on the table
and uh tbd
joel have i considered moving out of the
us recently things seem to be getting
really crazy if so
where is interesting to you well
my general feeling is choosing the
option that then presents or provides
the most options so it's likely
something that would provide access to a
larger geography whether it's in the eu
or commonwealth or something like that
but i'm not currently planning on moving
because i think wherever you go
there are going to be problems and i
think the problems are going to get more
and more complex and
more and more serious in many places
including in the eu
so rather than jump kind of out of the
frying pan and into the fire i'm also
going to focus on trying to improve
things here in the u.s and
i was born here i didn't choose to be
born here i am very grateful and
fortunate in
a million ways to have been born a
native english speaker in the united
states
and it's afforded me a lot of
opportunities so i feel some
karmic obligation to try to help here as
well so no immediate plans to jump
let's see
john as someone who seems to be
thoughtful about risk mitigation are
there any steps you're taking to prepare
for a society that seems to grow more
and more contentious all the time yes i
am planning on reducing my
internet footprint in certain respects
and probably disengaging from the most
polarized
and i think
polarized platforms and those platforms
will i think continue
to skew towards more extremes
and
certainly at this point i have no kids
once i have kids i expect i'll become
much more monk-like
in my predispositions and will care even
more about privacy now some of my
friends very smart people would say
privacy is dead that ship is sailed you
should just accept the privacy is dead
but it is still up to you what you
broadcast and what you share publicly
and that does have an impact on not only
your life but the lives of those around
you and i think this is particularly
important to consider when your say kids
do not opt in if they're not of an age
where they can give consent i kind of
like to assume that they haven't given
consent that's my current feeling maybe
i'll change my mind once i'm flooded
with hormones and decide i want to
plaster everything with photographs of
my kids who knows but i think that is
going to be my orientation
and i think having a plan b whether
that's a professional plan b
a geographic
plan b
income plan b
never hurts that's how i think about
these things but understand that i come
pre-packaged pre-programmed
with
some degree of paranoia and hyper
vigilance so i tend to skew
that direction i would say let me answer
one more then i'm going to jump to some
of the questions that were
submitted and
let's see
i will begin with
i believe this is a company name so i'm
going to skip it but i will
answer the question and that is can you
share an interview that was the most
impactful for you personally and i get
this question a lot
and my general answer is all of the
podcast episodes are personal to me in
some way they usually
are a result of me having some type of
question problem or goal or desire that
i can't quite figure out or would like
help figuring out and so i invite a
guest so at different points in my life
any given interview could be the most
impactful but one that i refer people to
a lot that had a big impact on me is
with bj miller
and
i'll let you look it up but bj miller at
the time he may do more now was a
hospice care physician who was a triple
amputee
due to an electrical accident when he
was in college actually and i had some
familiarity with the story has helped
more than a thousand he's probably
helped thousands of people to die at
this point to make that transition
so to speak which kind of alludes to a
number of other questions i received
today
and i highly suggest that if you haven't
heard it it is at least five years old
and
there's a lot to it and if you listen to
it two or three times you will learn
something new or notice something new
each time and there's a good amount of
overlap actually
in one respect with an ed cook interview
that i did this sort of cosmic
insignificance therapy which is actually
the name of a book excerpt that also
reinforces this point from forty
thousand is it four thousand weeks forty
thousand hours i always get mixed up
somebody can probably correct me but i
believe the book is four thousand weeks
i can never remember the number that's
one of the issues with the title but
oliver berkman is the author and if you
look up cosmic insignificance therapy on
tim. blog you will find it
i said i was going to do one more i'll
do a few more carlos manuel hey tim
would you consider doing a new version
of tribe of mentors your access to
really awesome people keeps growing yes
i've actually been considering doing a
new version
a new volume of tribe of mentors or
tools of titans
and i was thinking about that this
morning literally
because i was lamenting last night at a
dinner with a friend who is also a
podcast guest because he asked me
are you going to write another
volume of tribal mentors or two little
titans because he and this is a very
high performing guy
got a lot out of both of the books and
i
personally would like a reason to
not so much reach out to new people but
even more so to review
say the last 100 or 200 episodes of the
podcast
to glean what i may have forgotten to
highlight what i may have
failed to implement and so on and so
forth the motivation would very much
echo what is written in the introduction
or the preface to
tools of titans it would be for me
personally and the assumption there
being that if i do it for myself that
readers at least some readers will find
it interesting
okay let me
jump into some of these questions that
are the selected questions which came in
as being pre-submitted we've got between
400 and 500 people
now on the line so let me jump into that
and then i promise i'll come back and
we'll
answer some more live questions so the
first pre-submitted question
is from ariana and i'm going to read
this not necessarily because i have a
great answer but just because it may
open the door
and provide
a tool to people who are listening and
i'm going to look into this so here is
the
question
i am an ifs therapist and for those
people who don't know what that means
ifs is internal family systems
i don't love the naming of this system
but the results are really
undeniable at least in a lot of friends
and also for myself personally and i
interviewed richard schwartz who is the
founder
creator of ifs although parts work has
existed in different capacities and been
used in various modalities for some time
coming back to the question i'm an ifs
therapist and have had a couple of folks
find me specifically from looking up ifs
after hearing you talk about it i'm
super curious have you ever explored the
side of ifs that helps folks explore
inherited trauma slash energy ifs refers
to this line of inquiry as exploring
quote legacy burdens end quote
the way you talk about your depressive
and angry parts makes me wonder if any
of the energy that those parts carry
feels inherited and i guess i'd love to
hear your riff on that so i'm not going
to riff for too long on this but i will
say that absolutely both of those two
specifically
feel
inherited and i am going to look into
legacy burdens and may chat again with
uh richard dick about that and perhaps
i'll do a round two on the podcast to
explore that specifically or at least do
a session with an ifs therapist looking
into that
so that is my very short and sweet
answer
which is really a non-answer it's just
to say that is an interesting point that
you raise i will look into that so thank
you ariana
next question up is from sam
and his question is did you get any
happier when you got rich
what do you think a healthy view of
money is so i'll i'll take this as a as
an opportunity to give a shameless plug
to
a friend of mine actually ramit sethi
and
scthi and his podcast which i think is
just i will teach you to be rich it may
have a different name but if you just
find ramit sethi and his podcast
each episode and i've listened to a ton
of them he has generally a couple on and
they talk about their money
issues their money priorities what it
means to live a rich life
and what you realize very quickly is
that
people have neuroses
or stories at the very least around
money
that
both help and hurt them no matter how
much money they have so he can talk to a
couple where
they barely have enough money to scrape
by and they're hundreds of thousands of
dollars in debt or he can talk to a
couple that's worth 10 million dollars
and is still comparison and shopping for
strawberries
and
at the very least it normalizes some of
the unanswered questions and maybe
unrealistic expectations that people
have around
money to answer your question directly
i would say that
it's hard for me first of all to point
to a line after which
i felt
rich if that makes any sense whatsoever
and
that
if for the time being and i'm borrowing
this from someone else i think it was a
podcast guess but the value or cost of
something being the amount of life
energy you exchange for it
so you give to it or get from it right
in the in the
sort of pro and con positive and
negative sides of things
and
what i've noticed for a lot of my
friends is that past a certain point
wealth actually turns into a
energy consuming
facet of their lives and this is not to
complain uh because certainly i feel and
i am extremely fortunate for a million
reasons
uh but i have observed people who while
they are on the hunt while they are on
the journey to become rich and i'm
putting that in quotation marks in my
mind because i think the goal posts tend
to move for people
and it is and can be a very nebulous
goal but implicit in that is very often
the assumption that once i have this
money once i am rich once i have won
that game
most of my problems or
many of my problems will be solved and
um on maslow's hierarchy if we're
talking about shelter food
right so rent or mortgage etc that type
of thing it can be true
but the psychological psycho-emotional
issues uh tend to not just not get fixed
but sometimes get exaggerated so
by that i mean power alcohol money tend
to magnify whatever is there it's also
true with psychedelics for a lot of
people
and if you have say paranoia or you're
worried about people ripping you off
fill in the blank it could be any number
of things if
you feel insecure in ways a b and c
all of those levers i just mentioned
including money tend to amplify those
things if someone's generous they're
going to be super generous if someone's
a stingy [ __ ] they're going to be a
super stingy [ __ ]
and so on and so forth
and
what i found is that people can be very
happy and often are very upbeat
when they can hold in their mind the
belief
that
once they
cross the finish line these problems
will be fixed once they have the money
more often than not they realize that's
not the case and it can actually
result in
different types of and maybe
more intractable types of depression or
malaise because then it's like well wait
a second for 20 years 30 years i've
assumed this would solve the problem it
didn't now what
and
on top of that i would say once you have
team once you have more stuff let's say
somebody buys a second house
etc all of that consumes life energy on
some level and you can create systems
and so on but it does create
a bandwidth drain
and for instance if you have a bunch of
money
people are going to ask you for that
money constantly in some form or another
and you will feel compelled
most people will to think about
investing a lot
and generating that initial wealth and
being really good at investing are two
entirely different sports
so you may be very well suited to the
former and very ill suited to the latter
so again coming back to your direct
question did i get any happier when i
got rich i would say that having a
certain degree of relief especially when
thinking about caring for
aging parents when thinking about
being able to help family members being
able to help family members and close
friends during something like covid for
instance especially in the beginning
when there was a lot of uncertainty and
having some capital made a difference in
terms of
having optionality and moving people
around and so on
all of those things i would say
give me a greater peace of mind
and a certain degree of stillness but
on the other side of the ledger there's
a lot of [ __ ] that eats energy what do i
think a healthy view of money is i would
suggest that you actually
listen to
my podcast episode with morgan hausell
h-o-u-s-e-l
on the psychology of money this was a
hugely popular episode and i thought it
would be reasonably popular but it ended
up getting a lot of spread via word of
mouth and becoming mega popular so i'd
suggest listening to that i would also
say i don't have all the answers because
i fit in the category of someone who
thought money would fix tons and tons
and tons of things and be able to
exhale and go maybe lay on a beach and
rub cocoa butter on my belly and read
novels and be perfectly content to do
that for months and months of the year
turns out not to be the case also if
you're accustomed to driving in sixth
gear on the autobahn and you've done
that for 20 30 years getting used to
like driving through a school district
and stopping at red lights and so on at
20 miles an hour
is not automatically easy to do you you
think it would be but if you're used to
park or mostly sixth gear getting used
to the gears in between
at least for me personally has been very
challenging so
i'm still working on it and
i think this is a fascinating
fascinating question so i may not have
given much clarity
but
that is my my current state of play with
these questions
matthew correcting the title 4 000 weeks
the book that i mentioned earlier oliver
berkman great book
more highlights in that book and
psychology of money actually by morgan
haswell than probably any books in
recent memory for me
all right next question
is
chris from annapolis
tim you've mentioned before that podcast
guests have final say
over content in their interview and they
can cut out any parts that they aren't
comfortable with has there ever been any
interview where the guest or you decided
it wasn't up to standard and was never
published in the podcast
the answer is yes that has happened it
has not happened
recently but i would say in total of the
600 plus episodes that we have recorded
there are maybe six to ten that have not
been published and it is true that i
give
every guest final cut which is also what
inside the actors studio
did certainly with james lipton
and it's it's not that uncommon a policy
given the
format of the podcast and the intention
which is much closer to say how i built
this with gairaz than it is to hardball
or something like that where i'm looking
to pin people in a corner and
get them with gotchas and
have some type of controversy and that's
the main hook i use for my audience it's
not the intention
so i find it very easy to offer people
final cut however i will say there are
conversations occasionally and first of
all i'd say fewer than a three percent
of guests ever take advantage of that
and the intention is to say rather than
self-censoring in the interview and this
is true with writing as well you don't
have your
your genesis engine your creative engine
and your editing engine running at the
same time it's just not a great way to
put out great work i don't think so and
you know you have not that you want to
model hemingway in all things but the
kind of
right drunk edit sober approach applies
to podcasting so what i tell people
before we start recording
and i say quite a few things before we
start recording but one of them is
just
go all out right come out raw
share the details tell the stories and
we can always cut them later but don't
self-center right assume we've had two
glasses of wine each we're decent
friends
and that's the kind of conversation
we're having just the two of us and then
we can always cut things out later and
that's generally the phrasing however if
there is a section
and this has only happened once or twice
where they say you know i'd really like
to remove this but i think the section
is important
my general
response there will be
i'm happy to cut this but what that's
going to mean is the interview itself
cannot stand on its own two legs and i
can't publish the interview so if you
don't want that component of the
interview to be included we just have to
shelve the interview and
that has yet to result
in an interview being shelved so those
are some of my thoughts and approaches
on
final cut and how that applies to
podcasts there are many ways to do this
so there are plenty of folks who don't
do that with guests but
i have been too often in the interviewee
seat i mean i've been interviewed
hundreds probably thousands of times and
i'm just operating
using the the golden rule here treat
others as you would like to be treated
so i will also ask people before we
start recording in case you're
interested i'll say a number of things
right first it's not live so if you want
to go to the bathroom get water
pause and ask me a question
if you want to
stop something because it's not coming
out the way you want and restart your
answer you can do all of those things
and we can make it sound better in post
so don't worry about it
and i will also ask them what would make
this a home run three months from now
when you look back what would make you
thrilled that you took the time to do
this interview and are there any ways
you would like me to direct the
narrative or attention doesn't mean i'm
going to be a shill for someone's
publicist i don't do that
but
i would say next to no one asks anyone
that
and
for most folks who i have on the podcast
when i ask that question they say wow
i've never been asked that before
and
they very often have good answers so it
helps to inform the conversation it
makes them more comfortable
it
tells them hopefully
that i am an ally and not an enemy
that i've been in their seat before and
it just makes the entire process more
pleasant and more fruitful again if we
think about the
right drunk edit sober type of approach
to audio i find it super helpful all
right next one brian
i have rarely come across c.s lewis fans
or admirers outside of christian circles
what makes him compelling to you
including your praise of the movie the
most reluctant convert all right
so i will answer this cs lewis i
first
discovered as a writer so i did not i
did not discover him as a christian and
then move to his writing i simply found
his prose and his writing
spectacular and
i enjoyed
the
craftsmanship and the brilliance
and i still do that goes into his
writing and i do think he's also
cross-demographic and mainstream in the
sense that
he wrote the chronicles of narnia
which
may very well be an allegory for
for christianity and and central figures
and beliefs in christianity however
the chronicles of narnia i was looking
this up before
doing this q a has sold more than 100
million copies in 47 languages at least
based on wikipedia so it has crossed
over into mainstream but i find him
compelling because of his writing and
also thinking the most reluctant convert
i don't recall how i first found that it
was probably because i was looking for
documentaries about c.s lewis and this
particular film
is
is fact-based or non-fiction
history-based
but it is acted and it started off as i
understand as a one-man show on broadway
or off-broadway but as theater and the
main older actor who plays c.s lewis
narrating his own life is so good i mean
the acting is so so incredibly good that
i recommended it but it is not for
religious reasons
that i recommended c.s lewis
and i will look up actually one book
again it's going to sound strange
perhaps
but
that i found fantastic that has very
strong religious
implications and overtones but the
screwtape letters
by c.s lewis i absolutely loved i read
it more than 20 years ago so i may be
missing something that doesn't jibe with
current political correctness or
something else and if if so sorry about
that but
those are the reasons for which i find
c.s lewis
really really really interesting and i
should say at the same time that i read
the screw tape letters i was reading
bertrand russell and
you know why i am not a christian and
all these other books so my my interests
relate to the prose and thinking of
these people
and is not driven first and foremost by
belief system at least not one that i'm
aware of
there's always the question of
awareness and which beliefs
i've come to on my own and which i've
simply inherited from my family or
environment or upbringing or otherwise
okay let's jump into
the live questions and i will grab some
more from the chat
all right
uh from michelle hi from sunny scotland
that's not something you read every day
uh and i do love scotland but it hasn't
always been sunny when i've been there i
do love yaku
the scottish cows are amazing how do you
get things done when you're having a bad
day
i
will say this because i hope it makes
people feel better
when i'm having a really shitty day it's
very common that i don't get
much done or don't get anything done i
get to the end of my day and i've been
busy maybe and i can't remember a single
thing i could not write down
more than one perhaps things that i got
accomplished that were meaningful in any
way so hopefully that makes you feel
better
but
if i am trying to hedge that in some way
i would say
exercise and blue light
so using some type of light exposure
with a portable device i've used the
philips go light i believe it's called
before
which you can get on amazon or just
about anywhere else but light exposure
and exercise
for sure
would be
the prerequisite or kind of boot up
sequence that i would use
cold exposure oddly enough you wouldn't
think that
that that cold exposure would be
a real archimedes lever here but it does
affect dopamine release there's a lot of
literature to support this
and
for me at least has anti-depressive
effects that last a while it is not 10
or 20 minutes there is some durability
to it
and i find all those things very very
helpful
you know what i'm just in this i'm in
the
mode of confession today so let me give
another one adam i know your meditation
practice is somewhat fluid how does it
look today
it's so fluid in fact that i'm i've
completely fallen off the wagon and have
not been meditating for the last
at least month and i've excused that
i've
rationalized why that's okay in many
different ways and
at dinner last night was told in no
uncertain terms it's not okay and those
are all excuses so i intend to get back
on the wagon the way i'll most likely do
that is using the waking up app with sam
harris and going through his
very early initial
program which i think is somewhere
between 10 and 30 days
and
then i will also layer in
tm so transcendental meditation putting
aside some of the kooky stuff that's
associated with tm it's really just a
mantra based
repetition practice i find the
simplicity of that to
be very helpful
for getting back into the habit
and then we'll go from there i do find
loch kelly quite interesting
and
have been
consuming some of his lectures which are
quite short
and
that would be my approach to getting
back on the horse all right
let's see what else we have here
okay here's a question
do you think ivy league graduate schools
are worth the cost
it's so dependent on
personal details
whether you're taking on debt etc
i will say that my view of of higher
education and graduate degrees in
general is that
it depends a lot on the caliber and name
recognition of the school and also what
that does to your
professional opportunities
so if you're going to go to business
school does it make sense to go to the
174th best business school
in the us for a lot of people the answer
will be no if you get into harvard
business school and you're in
accounting or consulting or banking
may that open up opportunities and also
give you a nice
two-year
vacation of sorts where you can you know
play beer pong
while coming back to a higher position
after graduation quite possibly and in
some cases you can
actually in quite a few cases
those types of career tracks will pay
for
your further education so there are
instances where it can make sense but
i'm focusing on specifically the
question of graduate schools i think for
undergrad
the calculus is a little different and
you're going into say a liberal arts
education even if you're focusing in a
technical major
and
having
a
brand name of an ivy league school that
is globally recognized
has lifelong benefits so
if that can be achieved and paid for
without becoming an indentured servant
for the next 10 to 20 years i think it's
it's worth considering
all right
let's look at a few more all right
here's a question
thank you for the copy of the lion
tracker's guide what lesson would you
hope a loved one of yours would get from
it well if i if i consider myself to be
in the group of of my loved ones which i
don't always feel to be the case
i would say there's a line in there from
tracker
renis
which is i don't know where i'm going
but i know exactly how to get there
okay which refers to losing the track
not knowing where the animal eventually
will be found but understanding the
process
by which
you can get to that animal and trusting
in the process even when you lose the
track which is inevitably part
of tracking as i've spent more time
looking at it
i think that is one of the lines i would
come back to and one of the lessons i
would come back to over and over again
how do i handle overly political people
family friends i don't have overly
political friends i
break up with them
i'm not kidding generally
people family i
get very good at redirection to other
topics or i just request that we not
talk about politics nothing's going to
be solved
it's generally not always but generally
just salty old dudes bitching and
moaning
and i consider myself at this point a
salty old dude so let's be honest but
i just don't see anything productive if
someone is not actively in the arena
dealing with that and trying to solve
the problems they are
detailing sometimes in excruciating high
volume
then i just don't have any interest in
hearing it so
that's the short answer to that
okay
let me take a look give me a second
other than john mcphee are there any
essayists you recommend checking out
i would say essayist i mean ralph
waldo emerson comes to mind
but you may or may not consider him an
essayist
also
john muir comes to mind i mean i have
been reading a lot about
the history of yosemite
and also the
history of the national park system in
the u.s so i have been reading a lot of
writing from people who might be
described as transcendentalists or
naturalists so those are a few that come
to mind
let me look at a few more here
it's a question from michelle have you
read works by rudolf steiner thoughts on
his body work i haven't but i am
interested so that name has come up a
lot in the last few months
for for reasons that are not totally
clear so i intend on investigating that
this is a question uh from wine
i'll just say vine
are you going to publish your fiction
book in the real world so i'm not
currently working on a fiction book
there are a number of questions about
fiction and actually here's a question
from david
what is an unfinished project you have
that you still care about and would like
to finish at some point is there
anything i we in other words the
audience can do to help
so i i am in the process of thinking
about creating fictional worlds and also
but separately
writing a screenplay
and you know for what the audience can
can do i don't really have an ask at
this point in time i would say just
check it out when i share something and
if anyone is interested in my first
published piece of fiction
which deliberately i've only made
available in one format you can go to
tim dot blog nft i wrote a short story
not a big money maker by any stretch of
the imagination all the funds go to my
foundation
which is a non-profit and supports
research like the
various
novel treatments for say
major depressive disorder and so on ptsd
that sci say foundation is focused on
but
you can go to tim.blog nft and take a
look at that you can zoom in and read it
it's a little challenging to read but i
formatted it tried to format it in such
a way that you can do it pretty easily
all right
bear with me as i jump in here
what's the best purchase i've made over
over 250 in the last three years i was
expecting that to be under
the most recent purchase that i've been
enjoying quite a lot is something called
the so right pso hyphen rite for
soaz release it's a very simple piece of
plastic they have great margins on this
thing
and you can see it certainly on amazon
and on their website they have some good
how-to videos on their website
and that came up because i was trying to
find a way to
un-lock my lower back
which can cause
a lot of sleep disruption for me and i i
noticed that with say massage therapy or
good soft tissue workers if they if they
were
technical enough to really do a nice job
of releasing my iliacus
that i could sleep really well for at
least one or two nights
but i don't always have access to such
people
and wanted to find a way to do it myself
and this device is what popped up i
think it cost somewhere between 50 and
80 dollars
so that is
under 250 dollars
over 250
i would have to think about that i'll
meditate on that and i might come back i
don't
buy a lot of stuff i get sent a lot of
stuff that i just end up giving away so
i'm generally in purge mode and not
acquisition mode
all right here's a question
what would you recommend reading
listening to to learn about japanese
martial arts culture
i would recommend reading the historical
novel musashi
m-u-s-a-s-h-i
it is long and it is amazing it's one of
my favorite novels it is i believe the
best-selling novel in japanese history
so it was initially published in
japanese musashi
and if you would just like to hear a i
believe four-hour conversation about
this i was on jaco willing's podcast i
think it was for episode number 100 but
it could have been a different number
where he and i because he's also and if
you don't know jacqueline willink
retired navy seal commander has an
illustrious
career record
and a fascinating character all around
he had his first long-form public
interview on my podcast
and we talk in depth about
this novel and some of the details
within so i would say musashi is
probably the first that comes to mind
all right
let me see
okay
bear with
question i always get one of these
something like this did you lose your
razor you hippie
no but since i can't grow hair here i
like to grow what jason statham calls
the upside down face so i get the hair
on the bottom so if you rotated it it
would kind of look like a
a hair intact upside down head so i just
experiment with the facial hair and
frankly i'm too lazy to shave every day
all right
question from anand
if you had to recommend only one book
which one would it be right now today i
would recommend awareness by anthony
demelo i think it talks about some
foundational self-awareness
issues that
are the bedrock of functional or
dysfunctional life so that's probably
the first one that uh i would bring up
all right let me see
what else we have here
morenay
what one to three skills has made
acquiring more skills easier or
irrelevant
okay i'll mention
i'll mention three number one is
acquiring
relationships with polymaths who have
mastered multiple things if they have
mastered multiple very disparate
disciplines for instance
josh waits again in the case of chess
and then later tai chi and brazilian jiu
jitsu and foil boarding
who is at a very high level with all of
those
or in the case of a friend who's a very
good musician also a very good writer
ideally i like to
look for people who have mastered a
let's call it a mental discipline and a
physical discipline
then
i can generally get advice or
introductions from them
or
principals that will help me
with acquiring any skill i would like to
acquire
and then
if if i try to fill the three slots that
you offered i would say another one
would be learning
any language that is a second language
or a non-native language to a high
degree
is going to teach you a hell of a lot
about
not just fact acquisition so declarative
knowledge but the procedural knowledge
of producing novel sentences and
describing concepts when you don't quite
have
the vocabulary you will learn a lot
about how to
acquire other skills by becoming say
functionally fluent which i think you
can achieve generally in three to six
months
if we're talking about
languages that use a roman alphabet of
some type
you will find that a lot of the meta
principles that you gain from learning a
language will transfer to other areas
and if you haven't read the four hour
chef there's an entire section on metal
learning so the four hour shaft
confusingly is mostly focused on
accelerated learning so the meta
learning section of that
covers a lot of this but let's just take
a language so i would pick say japanese
in my case or spanish
and then
let's pick one japanese
which also got me familiar visually with
a different way of digesting and
encapsulating information in the form of
characters
and then pick a physical discipline so
it could be
in my case say judo could be archery
something that has a physical component
if you get
really good let's just say defining that
as top five percent of the general
population not competitive population
that could be applied to powerlifting as
well right you're not competing
against in that framing
people who are at the top of the
competition circuit you're just looking
at say your body weight to deadlift
ratio for
general population if you can figure out
a way to assess that
so if you have one mental let's say in
my case japanese
and then which includes both declarative
and procedural then you have a physical
right now for me it's archery but let's
just say it's
judo back in the
day and then having the relationships
with at least a few people who are doing
something similar right so they are
polymaths or multidisciplinary
in a way that includes at least
one primarily physical and one primarily
mental skill i think you can obviate the
need to try to
collect in some ad hoc way
a lot of disparate things and you can
you can pick and choose and be very
effective when you pick and choose
all right
let's see
margaret
uh you have question looking back at
your childhood what is your favorite
fairy tale or folk story i was i was
just thinking about this
before recording actually and i don't
know if this will count as fairy tale
but i was
thinking of
i think prompted by the question about
cs lewis that took me to chronicles of
narnia and i started thinking about the
never-ending story
i loved the nevr running story the book
when
i was young and i misbehaved in school a
fair amount and i would get sent to
detention
but what they didn't realize
is i loved detention because detention
was in the library and so i could skip
these classes that bore the hell out of
me and just read whatever i wanted and
the neverending story was definitely one
of my absolute favorites i think it has
a lot of philosophy embedded in it that
is actually intended for more adult
audiences
and
for that reason i would like to reread
it
but i would i haven't thought of this in
a long time i would actually take the
never ending story and i would hide it
in the library so that it wouldn't get
taken out before my next detention and
in that way i would be the only person
who knew where the never-ending story
was and i could always continue where i
left off
where i left off so that is one okay
this is from udo or yudo i apologize i'm
not sure on the
on the pronunciation what did i most
enjoy or find fascinating about learning
german and what did you find especially
annoying or challenging about it i'll
start with annoying or challenging
it was also interesting to me but the
articles and the declination of the
articles so
the fact that you have
masculine feminine and neuter for
uh just to be clear right indefinite
articles a and in english or definite
articles the so
uh
not only that but if it's like dative
accusative or whatever
you have all these different
adjustments based on if something is say
being used to indicate a direct or
indirect object right so you can have
dia di das then you have
you know dem which would be for the
dative
and uh
you have
aina inis einem then you have the the
genitive it goes on and on and on so
part of the reason i forget german
the fastest most quickly out of all the
languages i have taken a stab at is
because
as you would expect right just like
people like german engineering it's a
very precise language and there are a
lot of rules and
the articles and so on uh drove me nuts
i found challenging also
the number of
prepositions of sorts
that are thrown onto the front of verbs
and i won't get into a ton of examples
here but i found that challenging
what did i enjoy about it
i enjoyed learning a lot about older
english and the etymology of certain say
older english or even modern english
words
looking at germanic roots i really
enjoyed that
i really enjoyed the german people also
when i was in berlin i just had a great
time in berlin and i found
in general the germans to be
[Music]
very
warm and very funny uh very blunt in
their humor which i appreciated i think
maybe coming from new york
growing up in new york i found it pretty
easy to
digest all of that
and i i really
enjoyed and this is going to be a
problem for some people but i enjoyed
how the sentence structure and the word
ordering can change very very
dramatically depending on
how things are laid out so for instance
in
in english or in mandarin chinese
the sentence structure is pretty
consistent
it is
subject verb object right i ate the
apple i go to school whatever
and in german
now in japanese you have the opposite
it's it's i to the library go i the
apple eat and also pretty consistent
german has both and english to some
extent has a few exceptions but german
will have like ish
right i think that and then
wait wait wait wait wait verb and in the
beginning
i found that confusing as hell
and it was really hard for my working
memory as an english speaker to hold on
to all of this crap that i needed to
remember before we got to the verb
and when my brain became more accustomed
to that i just it it felt like some type
of
let's just say you had the equivalent of
like a frozen shoulder in your brain and
then it suddenly regained its range of
motion it had that sensation in the
brain for me
so there we go
here's a question any updates on the tim
ferriss fragrance for men you know
this has been one of those stupid things
that i've wanted to do for a long time
that may end up being not that stupid
much like i've always wanted to be able
to do the side splits between chairs
like van damme i think i may give that
one up it's been on my new year's
resolutions for like 35 years
but the fragrance for men may be
forthcoming so keep an eye out and uh in
fact that may become a thing
all right let me
check a few more and then i will jump to
the pre-submitted
okay so this is a question from
here's one
oh that's funny all right so i think
this is a real estate agent in germany
yeah i'm already 15 years in german but
still difficult totally feel you i feel
you all right this is a question from
auntie fragile i will read it
as it would be pronounced in english
what role has downtime had on the
severity of your depression this is a
great question and i actually think it
has been also in the pre-submitted
questions so i will i will give a stab
now
what role is down time had on the
severity of your depression how can one
make time for one's creative pursuits
while diminishing the vulnerability such
mental space solitude can summon this is
a very good question and i think about
this a lot
because there are times when i'm tempted
say to go to
two weeks in nature by myself
but there's definitely part of me that
is concerned that when i provide that
amount of negative space or empty space
that the thoughts and the loops that
creep in
will be
of some character that bring about
depression or anxiety mostly depression
and
one might advise me that that's true
initially and then it clears out however
i have counter examples and this is true
for my vipassana retreat that i've
spoken about at some length in the past
and spoke about at some length on dan
harris's 10 happier podcast
so if you want to hear more about that
you can
listen to the 10 happier podcast that
dan harris did with me but
i had a complete
psychological breakdown at this
vipassana retreat silent retreat
and i didn't make my life any easier by
making it much more extreme and
exaggerated in a few respects one was
coming into it six days fasted because i
really wanted to make the most of this
limited amount of time but
that is a concern so first of all i just
want to validate that by saying you're
not the only person who thinks about
this this is something that i certainly
think about
but your question isn't so much
one about
solitary time it's a question about
downtime now it seems like you're
equating down time to making time for
one's creative pursuits
the way i think about this is a little
bit different and i would say for me
creative pursuit right now
is
dictated by
who can i interact with even if it's
just once a week even if it's once every
two weeks
how can this bring me closer to someone
i want to be closer to
and for me it's mostly pre-existing
friendships
but part of my reason
the primary reason that i've thought
about doing something incredibly absurd
and effectively a parody of the space in
the nft world
is because i have all these old friends
who are scattered around the country
and we used to all be in
san francisco together and we spent a
lot of time together and had so much fun
and then
life progresses people get married
people have kids people move away
and
web 3 is one of the first times that
i've seen almost all of these people
get back on the same playing field in a
way where they are interacting and
having fun
and this this by the way is not a
recommendation to invest in web 3 or
nfts i think you should assume
that pretty much everything could go to
zero and a lot of these things will go
to zero so this is not investment advice
this is psychological commentary for me
in terms of choosing projects so i am
actually choosing the playing field
first and then i'm deciding alright
which sport do i want to play on that
playing field which position do i want
to play on that playing field but it's
actually starting with the who and not
starting with the what if that makes any
sense and i found that and have found
that at least so far to be very helpful
to my mental state in the sense that it
bolsters me it feeds me it nourishes me
as opposed to making me feel like i'm
stepping out to a cliff and peeking over
the side where i can say yeah this is a
great view but if one foot slips i could
find myself in trouble hopefully that
helps
megan
what have i been reading listening to
lately that has impacted your thinking
about parenthood well
i have something right next to me uh
and i'll just pull two books so the
first i don't even know if this has been
published yet it was sent to me by kevin
kelly who's
an incredible human being and i i still
think probably the most interesting man
in the world in reality so i would
suggest listening to my first podcast i
did with kevin kelly but he sent me this
little book it's called excellent advice
for living
seeds for contemplation and these are
based on his
i want to say for the last two or three
years his annual what i've learned lists
where he turns 68 and he put together i
think 68 bullets and then he turned 69
he put together another 69 bullets and
this little book contains i want to say
between 300 and 400 of such bits of
advice
kevin
is also one of the most engaged and i
would say successful
parents
and spouses i've ever seen so i find
kevin
to be a role model worth studying so
that doesn't directly answer your
question perhaps but
for me it's about understanding
someone's complete picture well enough
that you don't cherry pick one piece
and find it
later to your detriment to be hitched to
everything else right so what i mean by
that is
in the world of business for instance or
investing
i know a lot of young men make this
mistake they're like okay i want to
emulate and i'm sure young women make
this mistake or older men and women but
they'll say i want to emulate fill in
the blank investor
he or she has compounded 20 for the last
17 years
that's what i want because i want to be
rich and what they may neglect to do is
go on to wikipedia and read about this
person and realize they're on their
seventh marriage
and that you can't automatically
cherry pick
one piece of someone's life
and
force fit it into your own
and safely assume that other parts of
your life will not change as a result of
inserting that right
so in kevin's instance i feel like i
know kevin well enough we've traveled
around the world together
and i've seen him with his family i've
been to his house i've spent time with
him he's not one of my closest friends
but i know well enough to think
okay holistically
kevin has figured a lot out he also
lives in a very non-consensus way but he
does it
through reasoning and by paying
attention to his sort of internal
compass not simply to be a contrarian so
for all those reasons i find kevin kelly
fascinating and you could certainly just
look up his
what i've learned birthday posts if you
can't find excellent advice for living
that's the first one
and the next one which i've had on my
shelf for a very long time is this this
is and i think i'm going to be
pronouncing this
correctly but sorry if i'm not dear
author
johann hari i believe it's johan but
somebody could probably
correct me if i'm wrong j-o-h-a-n-n
last name h-a-r-i this book is lost
connections and the subtitle is
uncovering the real causes of depression
and the unexpected solutions and
most of this relates as far as i can
tell now in fairness i'm only reading
part three
i'm skipping the description of all of
the causes of depression and i'm
skipping all the descriptions of the
issues and jumping straight to part
three which is reconnection or a
different kind of antidepressant and
really reading about social cohesion
and
social structuring
that might be a strange way to put it
but how to think about
cohabitating
neighborhoods
community
such that
parenting among other things can succeed
so rather than saying how can i be the
best parent
which is certainly a question i'm sure
i'm gonna beat to death once i get
closer to having kids
but putting that aside for the second
asking rather how can i set the
conditions
such
that the likelihood of a kid turning out
well
happy and healthy to the extent that's
possible with some genetic
determinism maybe
how can i do that through thinking about
where we live
who is around us
what support structures exist and so on
so those are
two quick answers to your very short
question thank you
all right there's a question from
anthony
dream guests who are dream guests
there are there are there's a long list
of folks you know i thought about oprah
of course and and many others
but sometimes the juice is not worth the
squeeze with mega celebrities you just
have to interact with so many layers
of people and a phalanx of lawyers
and the manager and the agent and the
publicist and the publicist assistant
and
all of that
that when you finally get to the
interview you feel worn down and it can
take a year a year and a half two years
three years to get these things done so
i i've not pursued that very hard even
though i would love to do it
i think oprah's incredible and for those
interested in learning more about her
the making of oprah is a short
miniseries podcast
that i've only listened to the first
season of but i found it very
interesting
others that come to mind
would be daniel day-lewis even though
frankly i'm not sure
he would ever do it and secondly i have
not listened to many long-form
interviews but i think he's such a
spectacular performer
that it could be interesting and he is
very hard to get a hold of so there's
there's part of that that is
appealing to me in and of itself ryan
reynolds i think would be incredible and
there are there are certainly many other
and i've checked off a lot of my dream
guests if you think about jane goodall
you know i wanted to have her on the
podcast since day one
fortunately you know madeleine albright
margaret atwood just to name a few
and many others hugh jackman and also
thinkers i wanted to have on for a very
long time scientists who are lesser
known
uh so those are a few who come to mind
but what i have come to realize for
myself
is number one
one of the best ways to grow a podcast
is to focus on mega celebrities and
controversy
and i have almost no interest in doing
either of those things
so once i let go of that
and have viewed this podcast as
something that nourishes me hopefully as
much as it nourishes other people
you can find fascinating people who will
give you
incredibly good
conversations and takeaways and
actionable philosophies
and deep thinking
everywhere they are everywhere
in any given country
any given
gender race creed
you can find them so
i don't worry too much about the wish
list anymore but yeah i do have a short
wish list
and uh at the very least i think maybe
i'll give it a stab like once every six
months we'll throw out a long lead and
see if we can get a marlin
okay
let me
let's see all right this is a question
from
aaron oh aaron's dropped quite a few
questions in let me pick one
all right i'll pick the one that
maybe i can answer this is from aaron
e-r-i-n did you mainly take a break from
investing because of losses in the
market before returning to crypto
investing how do you feel about the bear
market now no i did not take a break
from investing because of losses in the
market
i took a break from investing for a
bunch of
separate reasons
and
i'm just going to search for it right
now so i can tell you
wow geez
all right so i wrote a post in 2015
which explains it well
and it is how to say no when it matters
most
and then in parentheses or why i'm
taking a long startup vacation
and this was a very popular post october
29 2015
how to say no when it matters most or
why i am taking a long startup vacation
and we'll put the link in the show notes
but i will also
drop the link
into the chat so people can check that
out and those are my reasons for taking
a break it really related to having time
for deep work and focusing on other
projects
did not have anything to do with losses
i'd actually uh at that time done quite
well i did however want to wait given
the size of my given the number of
private investments
to see how many turned out because i i
did not have complete confidence i still
don't have complete confidence that i'm
very good at angel investing even though
i've had a number of wins
you don't want to count your chickens
before they've hatched in this case you
don't want to count your chickens before
a liquidity event so i wanted to also
wait and focus on other things
and
my crypto investing was around that time
mostly so i have not been speculating or
day trading
or playing much at all in
crypto for the last several years i'm
watching it very closely and i'm
interested in aspects or i should say
related marketplaces and technologies
that are underpinned or at the very
least denominated in some
sense in say eth or other
cryptocurrencies
but
i think a lot of what's going on in
crypto web 3 the vast majority of it's
going to end in tears and it's going to
run red so
that is not to give again any investment
advice but just to tell you about my own
thought process i've been mostly on
the sidelines how do i feel about the
bear market now i think that
no one should be surprised i think no
one should be surprised by this and that
what goes up comes down and
that
i am preparing to be in what we would
consider not just a bear market but a
full-fledged recession with high
inflation for quite some time
so i am not
currently in the mode of deploying as
much capital as possible into what
one
might think of as the bottom of the
market that is not how i'm viewing
things so
i'm definitely measuring twice and
cutting once and i am
personally holding on to
significant cash reserves now that could
prove to be
the wrong decision if my goal were to
optimize for maximum return on
investment and
compound an annual growth rate and so on
but right now
i am optimizing for sleeping well at
night and
fortunately don't spend a lot of money
on too much expensive [ __ ] so i
don't need to feed that monster too
badly
all right johan hari is a worthy podcast
guest yes
andre i believe reading this correctly i
agree with you so maybe i'll get him on
at some point
all right
let me jump
matthew you're saying it's strangely
satisfying when my head
fits perfectly into the painting behind
you there you go
check it out
all right
all right thank you for that commentary
i appreciate it
not done on purpose
let's jump into some of the
pre-submitted questions
all right
next is
i'd like your perspective on this quote
if being hard on yourself worked it
would have worked by now end quote does
that ring true in your own
self-compassion journey and how do you
feel now about your relationship to
yourself and especially what you expect
from yourself having been on that
journey for some time now
so i would say that much work
remains to be done
for me with respect to self-compassion i
am i'm still very brutal when it comes
to
self-commentary and criticism
i do think it's improved some
incrementally improved and to reflect on
the quote because you asked for that
if being hard on yourself worked it
would have worked by now right now
something akin to this also would be if
working harder on this worked
it would have worked by now right or if
asking for this worked
in the context of say a significant
other or something like that if asking
for this in the way you've been asking
worked it would have worked by now
is
i suppose a
mantra for remembering that if you
repeat the same thing over and over
again expecting different results you
are engaging in some form of insanity
however
i think the challenge when we dig into
the nuances here
and the practical results
of
being hard on yourself is that
being hard on yourself works for some
things
right i do think having
almost impossibly high standards and
just whipping your back with the help of
the demons in your psyche and whatever
collected trauma you like to use as
a form of boulder
pushing you forward
does work for some things right it works
for piling in the hours it works for
distracting yourself with a manic focus
on
building your business for instance or
something like that so it's not totally
useless i think therein lies part of the
challenge that
being hard on yourself does work or
seems to help for some things
does it work for
increasing your feelings of
contentedness
does it work for increasing your feeling
of
spaciousness and ease
i don't think so certainly that's not
the case
and
i feel like i've solved for many things
in my life but that is that last
collection of three or four things i
just mentioned
is one that i continue to try to solve
for and i think many of you who listen
to the podcast regularly will have
noticed that in the guests and the type
of questions that i ask
so
if
anyone is
struggling with that or finding that to
be a challenge you are not alone
certainly at least
nathaniel who has the question and yours
truly count is two but i know this is
this is a very pervasive
challenge for
almost everyone i talk to not everyone
but almost everyone you know who seems
to have it figured out although it's
hard to tell
if he came out of the box this way is
kevin kelly which is another reason why
i find him fascinating and want to make
a study of him
okay
next question
here we go considering dunbar's law of
having a max of 150 meaningful contacts
how do you manage the relationships and
friendships with all the amazing people
you've met over the years and especially
through the podcast
they all seem like people you would want
to stay in contact with
all right
let me take
take a second to try to tackle this i
agree with dunbar's law having a max of
150 meaningful contacts in fact i would
say it's a lot lower than that for me i
don't think i can maintain more than a
few dozen meaningful contacts
meaningful
here defined as
relationships that i communicate with
say
once at least once every two weeks
and this is partially a function of just
how much inbound
gets directed at me and my team i mean
thousands of inbound messages
if you count email social et cetera that
blog and so on it is it is impossible
physically impossible to digest and
respond to all of those
uh so i do think there's there's a
certain degree of decision fatigue that
feeds into this but
i would like to say that
there are a few things that help me not
feel
stress around keeping in touch with
people
or staying in contact with people
the first is if you know
one person who is really really
good they don't even need to be famous
but just very very
competent
i was about to say gifted but that's not
the same thing
someone who has cultivated a high degree
of expertise and ability in any field
that could be
neurosurgery that could be
applied linguistics that could be
venture capital
if you know one person
you can get to anyone else in that field
generally speaking assuming that person
you know isn't a total bastard
uh
so you will be able to get to just about
anyone like if you know one of the
if you get to know someone who is a
national finalist in the dog agility
championships you want to find someone
in the dog world especially in the
competitive arena
you can find that person if you know one
so you really just need a to hold in
and i would say also i know a lot of
podcasters and those podcasters very
often do
something akin to what i do so they also
have their own collection of these
wedges so to speak
last i would say
that
busy people and most of the people i
have on the podcast are busy in one form
or another
do not expect
nor do they desire to keep in contact
with or to keep up with many people
and if i have a two hour meaningful
conversation with them and if i do my
homework if i do my prep if my team
helps me do that
if they come away from the interview
thinking to themselves holy [ __ ]
that was an experience
and
i've never quite had an interview like
that before
that was really well architected that
was really well directed the questions
were
reflective of a really high degree of
homework
i'm surprised i enjoyed that so much
i do not need to email that person a
month later
to ping them to
keep
my name top of mind
and i think it would actually damage
those relationships if i did that
routinely
so
the folks that i select to have on the
podcast and the people who self-select
to be on the podcast generally just by
virtue of being world-class whatever
they do
tend to be
low maintenance
seeking low maintenance
and they look for
density of
meaning and connection
rather than frequency
so i i really don't feel compelled
to
stay in contact with folks
who have who have established that
baseline connection with
unless there's something meaningful to
ask them or to offer them or otherwise
so there you have it yeah i mean i
really uh there are hundreds of people
i've had on the podcast who
i haven't had any contact with in years
but if i were to email them or text them
i believe they would respond
if they're able
and
it comes down to i think prep
and this is reflected also in their
interactions with my team so from start
to finish what was their experience and
if it was great
most of them i think are open to having
some type of dialogue after the fact
even if we've had no contact whatsoever
and this relates also to a presentation
i gave at south by southwest which may
be worth listening to for some folks and
i put on the podcast
which is i believe titled
sounds a little hyperbolic but how to
build a world-class network in record
time
and i gave this to south by southwest
because the organizers asked me if i
would do a session explaining how to get
the most out of south by southwest which
is a huge
huge huge huge
festival slash conference
so
i would say start there and those are
those are some of my thoughts
all right let me while molly pup my dog
is drinking water extremely loudly let
me look at
some of the live questions
and i will i'll do my best to answer a
couple here
let's see here
okay
this might take a second
this is i'm just gonna be silent for a
minute while molly screws around with
old balls right next to me
so many questions all right
what would my advice be to 21 year old
tim probably
drink a little bit less exercise a
little bit more start meditating and do
not participate in anything as an
impulse that you think might destroy
your shoulders
uh i would say those are a few that come
to mind immediately
morenay are there any of the principles
or ideas in the four-hour work week you
think apply less today
principles no i think the principles as
far as i can recall and i did look at
the book recently because i had a
question like this come up
the principles i think still apply
equally if not even more so
in today's environment honestly with the
amount of destabilization with remote
work
with
experiments and decentralization with
rentable infrastructure and services i
think the principles
if you are looking for
self-determined security per se if
you're looking for preserving
optionality i think the principles in
the four-hour work week apply more so
now than when the book first came out
the specific tech tools and so on that
are mentioned in some parts of the
four-hour work week like go to my pc
clearly
are outdated and
a lot of the specific tools could be
updated but if you understand the
principles and the methods you can find
the specifics you will have the ability
to search and vet the particular tools
that suit your circumstances and
objectives and so on but i think that in
fact
the four-hour workweek principles apply
now more than ever and i'm remembering
another thing that reinforced this for
me is i was asked to write a new preface
to the german edition
of
the four-hour work week where the book
has been spectacularly successful
more copies have been sold in the german
markets than in the uk markets and
australian markets
and
maybe someone can explain to me why
germany and korea
seem to be such voracious book reading
cultures across the board my other
friends who are authors say the same
thing
but regardless the point was
i wrote a preface for
a new edition
the same as the revised edition in
english
of the four hour work week and i went
back and i looked at the book
as a review and i thought to myself
80 20
you know pareto's principle
parkinson's law is a helpful heuristic
dream
lining fear setting all these tools all
these principles seem to me to be
timeless
but
extremely timely in the current flux
that we're experiencing and i think
we'll continue to experience for some
time
so hopefully that is helpful and for
anyone who's wondering you can find
dreamlining if you search that and my
name you can find worksheets and so on
for free and if you're interested in the
fear setting as i described it that was
the subject of my
ted talk that i did a handful of years
ago and you can find that at tim.blog
ted and i also include some text as a
description
all right
question what are three things one
should do when visiting japan that you
wouldn't find on every travel blog
number one
try to go to
the ghibli museum
ghibli museum in inokashira park
it is
the most
wonderful
unusual museums i think i've ever been
to it's adorable so ghibli for those who
don't know is the equivalent of disney
in japan
founded by
miyazaki hail and this particular museum
is just
incredible and when i attended this may
have changed but they would give you a
ticket and the ticket contained a clip
of a real cell from one of their
animated films
and i just loved it when i was last in
japan you can get tickets for that at
lawson i think which is the equivalent
of say a 7-eleven
which
then brings me to a food recommendation
which is
to try to find
a
street side yakitori
or some type of really really low brow
cheap japanese food
and if you just search i'm sure you can
find which subway stop
would take you to
uh or which train stop would take you to
such a place where you can wander around
and have some some street food in japan
and in fact if you wanted to do two for
one inokashira park
at a number of entrances has
food kiosks where you can get any number
of things so if you wanted to do a
two-for-one you could do that and then
number three
i'm i'm shooting from the hip here
i would say
is
get incredibly lost
and don't take your phone
so
no using google maps
no using google translate
walk around do this during the day it'll
be a little easier to get back to where
you need to go
and
get incredibly lost and then find a
kobang which is a
police kiosk
and
you could have the hotel or airbnb
address or whatever on a card that's
fair game and then have them
with their almost
certain broken english help you get back
to wherever you need to be
that's an adventure that i think
everyone should have it is one of the
most alien places an english speaker
could visit while still being
almost completely safe i mean i i think
there's been a little bit more
violent crime in in japan since i was
there in say 92 93
and i've visited many times since but it
is still incredibly safe by global
standards
okay
let me look at one or two more and then
i will jump back to some of the presets
and i see now that we've been going for
an hour and a half i was only planning
on an hour
i will keep going probably for another
half hour for those people who are
willing to stick around just let me know
if you're still going to stick around if
you'll still stick around i'll keep
going so
let me know
question from goku what's the most
beautiful location you ever visited one
of them first that comes to mind is
queenstown new zealand
incredible incredible spot so that is
that is one that comes to mind but there
are many there are many many many places
certainly i could probably pick 10 in
japan alone
and
there's a lot
all right
let's see here
all right julie
what's your system to choose a focus in
business
pick up the 80 20 principle this is a
book
by richard koch koch
he may actually say his last name kash i
think that's how he says it you could
listen to my conversation with him which
was i think a very very solid
conversation
but the 80 20 principle i would just
pick up that book that is the shortest
answer that i can give while still being
helpful
and
let me see
yeah the four hour work week there's
some commentary on the four-hour
workweek in german
uh it is fun to see how it's translated
into other languages like uh danish is
something like fiatimas abba
and
i just loved learning all of the
translations because i'm such a language
nerd
so it's helpful to just
pick up you know 5 6 15 words
with each translation
all right
all right
i'm going to give this a shot this is a
question from cole
what sort of strategies have you applied
to overcoming grief after losing a loved
one suddenly
there seems to be a lot of bad content
platitudes when it comes to death and
grieving
i'll comment on this just because i
recently attended my uncle's funeral and
he died of alcohol at used
cardiomyopathy so
for those who are not aware i'm very
heavily involved in supporting
non-profit research related to
psychedelic therapeutics
and
these are often looking at
indications like major depressive
disorder treatment resistant depression
complex ptsd in the case of mdma
psychotherapy but at nyu you have
psilocybin for alcoholism and
psychedelics i do think apply more
broadly to different types of addictions
including thought
addictions which could be manifest
in ocd or anorexia nervosa etc
but
these are in some cases very deeply
personal for me so my my uncle became an
alcoholic when he was a child and
continued until he drank himself to
death in this case
and
we just had that
funeral it was really an internment
because he was cremated and
[Music]
i was surprised because i expected it to
be very somber maybe depressing
and
one or two family members
decided to tell really funny stories
about this uncle and
we spent a bunch of time together and it
ended up being
quite
unexpectedly
bonding for all of us to tell these
stories but to to focus on
the
the good and to focus on the funny
he was a joker and he was a joker it was
his personality so i think he would have
wanted that and it was
the most
uplifting i think
repairing
such service i've ever been to and so i
do think that there there's probably a
place for storytelling with an emphasis
in some cases on humor and i'm certainly
no expert in this by by any stretch
my friend matt mullenway who lost his
father very unexpectedly found
i think it's on grief and grieving
to be very helpful and
he has recommended that people read this
before they
lose loved ones so it seems to have some
not preventative but some preemptive
value on grief and grieving this is by
david kessler and elizabeth
kubler-ross
came highly recommended and i've
mentioned that
on podcasts with matt because i've had
them on several times and have had
tremendously positive feedback
from
listeners so i would say that would be
another possible recommendation although
i have not read it yet myself
all right let me jump into
some of the
submitted questions
and
then
it will keep going all right i'm going
to do a
quick one aj what are what was your
thought process and key decision factors
on moving from the bay area to austin
answer to that is check out my reddit
thread i wrote a reddit ama answer to
this that went somewhat viral so i would
just search tim ferriss move from san
francisco to austin reddit ama and it'll
pop right up has it worked out entirely
the way you anticipated short answer no
anything you'd change i don't think
there's anything i would change but i
did move to austin in part to get away
from any
mono conversation seen and
i anticipated when i moved there in 2017
that austin would become a scene
probably in
say
i don't know
seven
to nine years something like that
i did not anticipate that covid would
accelerate all of that
so significantly of course and i would
say that austin has become
a massive scene of scenes so that is
unfortunate but
it's also a great city has a lot to
redeem it itself and
there are reasons why people are moving
there but if you want the
the basic rationale check out my reddit
ama answer
and
here's a question
i saw a tweet recently that said quote
way too many young guys are taking life
advice from childless 40 year old men
end quote i'm a student in my early 20s
and i'm a voracious podcast listener
europod lex friedman biology interviews
neval etc i think this tweet was cynical
and off the mark but do you think people
at my stage of life should be careful
about relying too much on what they
learn from your generation
all right let's let's take a stab at
this
so i think that
people at any stage of life should be
careful about relying too much
on
any particular
single
archetype or demographic or
psychographic
right so i will point out also
biology has kids naval has kids
so those two
i would accept
from the question because they are not
childless
lex i don't believe has kids
i do not currently have kids
so
it also depends on
what type of advice you are
consuming
and
are these people
practicing what they preach are they
walking the walk and not just talking
the talk so
it depends for me
highly on the type of advice
so if i'm talking to let's say an ifs
therapist i'm not going to ask them for
say general contractor constructing
advice for a remodel that that i might
be in the middle of
i'm going to recognize
just like me just like anyone else there
are constraints and limits to the
expertise of any one person and i'm
going to look for practitioners so i
would say that
and if you are getting all of your
advice from people who fit neatly into a
handful of parameters let's just say
40 year old childless men
then i do think that is a
prompt for
pausing and
diversifying
but you know diversifying here really
just means
changing some of those variables
and i i think that is incredibly helpful
for
your intellectual health it is
incredibly helpful for
preserving a healthy level of skepticism
so you don't accidentally get
indoctrinated into the cult of
personality x
and
those are my general thoughts part of
the reason i do this podcast and kept
the tim ferriss show very broad in its
possible scope is i want to speak with a
very wide spectrum of folks if i only
were able to speak to business people
because this were strictly a business
and entrepreneurship show i would have
stopped doing this a long long time ago
and
i do try to follow the advice then that
i'm giving right now
and
that said
i will
also
underscore that
if you are studying and taking advice or
considering advice you should certainly
consider and stress test the advice
before implementing it then you are
ahead of a lot of people who just don't
do that at all
who are happy to regurgitate whatever
the latest news is that they've pulled
from their doom scrolling on twitter
and yell and shout on the internet so if
you are engaged in any type of
self-development you are already i would
say ahead of the curve but certainly
much like a physical diet
a spectrum of different foods
will likely cover more bases keep you
healthier
than
some type of strictly regimented
you know
monocategorical type of eating and
that's true for your information diet as
well so
i would say
that my general thoughts
are pretty pretty simple in that respect
all right
let's see here
already answered the downtime question
and
okay
i have a question here this is going to
be a bit of a long one
this is going to be a hard one too so
i'm going to take a little iced tea
break and do this and then i'll come
back also to the live questions after i
do this one and by the way you know we
received hundreds and hundreds of
submitted questions
and my first filter is
do i know anything about this right do i
have anything to
offer in a response that i think is
qualified that i've stress tested in any
way and if not i just do not answer
right so i try not to speculate i think
there's too much speculation
and in general
folks online speak with way too much
confidence so
i just want to say there are many
questions i'm not answering in the live
feed there are many questions i'm not
answering
that were lobbed in
some of them because they're asking for
really particular legal or medical
advice which is is just not something i
can do comfortably
but in
many cases including those i am just not
qualified i would be
misrepresenting myself as an expert and
in so doing on some level being
dishonest and lying to all of you and i
don't want to do that now this one we'll
see if i have anything so here goes
all right
i'm extremely driven to build my version
of a deep life filling it with things
that are meaningful and substantive
cutting out the frivolous and harmful
and hedonic pieces and avoiding the
seemingly infinite temptations of
american life that lead to a shallow and
frustrating existence
my fiancee has seemingly little interest
in the arduousness of this lifestyle
preferring ease and comfort as most do i
do not fault her at all for this
preference and i love her above all else
and fully plan on spending my entire
life with her but every time that i try
to convince her to tackle the task of
self-improvement with me it only leads
to arguments and hurt feelings since she
is essentially half of my identity how
do you think i should handle this
should i let it go and try to live half
my life in each camp i find that hard to
swallow since i'm fairly positive that
the comfortable american life basically
smooths out the contours of your soul
nice wording and i have an immensely
difficult time watching that happen to
her no i don't think that's an option so
i guess my final question is how do i
convince her to go on this journey with
me how do i convince her to
forego comfort and decadence especially
when i'm having a hard enough time doing
that myself all right that's a long
question
but i would like to
try to respond to it because
i and i think many people have contended
with this on some level it could be a
significant other it could be a very
close friend it could be
the five people you associate with most
and certainly
drew of dropbox and i and others have
said you are the average of the five
people you associate with most so if you
don't want to get rid of your friends
what do you do if this is an issue in
your
most intimate relationship with a
significant other what do you do and i
can only speak to a few things that i
have tried
because hitting it head-on with some
criticism along the lines of
why aren't you interested in self
development
is not going to be a crowd pleaser and
is not going to get the
response that you want
so
i'm going to answer this in two stages
the first
is related to an assumption that's
embedded in the first section of this
question
and that was you know should i let it go
and try to live half my life in each
camp i find that hard to swallow
no i don't think that's an option
and there is a
false dichotomy being created here so
the options that are being presented at
least in the question are live half my
life in each camp so half my life away
from my partner effectively or fully
integrate both of us so we are on the
same program
i'm exaggerating a little bit but that
is a false dichotomy there are other
options and there's a gradient i think
between those two so first what i've
learned is
some things you're just meant to do on
your own
and you don't have to do everything with
your significant other
however if you are going to say
take a week to do
a workshop or
a week for a solo expedition or whatever
it might be it could just be a week to
go to burning man i mean i'm not saying
that's self-development but
you
will benefit from
a relationship that can sustain that so
two people
who are fully capable of being say
self-entertained or self-directed at
least four stints at a time i think
that's important i i do that with my
significant other or just as easily i
could say she does that with me there
are times when we do our own thing
okay
that is component one and then to
the
direct last question how do i convince
her to go on this journey with me
to me convincing implies
speaking and
persuading
in conversation and i don't
know that is going to be the most
effective path what i have seen
personally and what i've also seen in
other couples
is the path of least resistance
is often identifying what they already
love
the things they already enjoy
the activities they feel drawn to
and trying to
bend the arc of one of those
one percent
to include what you consider to be
self-development right so
let's just say hypothetically
that your fiance i'm making this up
that she
loves going to yoga
well
you could suggest you could find
a
fantastic
teacher training course
and
if you know you have one to two weeks of
vacation coming up let's just say it's
in a nice location fill in the blank
could be in sedona could be in bali who
knows depending on your budget
and
you could
offer that as an early christmas present
early birthday present or just as a gift
and say that you would like to cover
that
and
you thought it could be super fun and
you've been wanting to spend more time
with her
in
her yoga practice so that you can do it
together and
that would be a
non-trivial step in the direction of
self-development i think that would be a
programmatic way
to improve
yoga capabilities
and familiarity with terminology and
also network etc right
so i think we want to meet people where
they are i don't always do a great job
of this i i can be very stubborn and
headstrong and aggressive so
i don't always implement this
in the most delicate or diplomatic way
but i have had success also with this is
just trying to first before you decide
what you're going to convince someone of
or where you want them to go
to meet them where they are do a mental
audit
of the things they love the things that
are easy for them to do
and then try to find a slight variation
on one of those themes that allows them
to step foot in a way that feels good to
them not just to you
towards a path of
self development i would also say
that
self-awareness
is a very powerful precursor to
self-development so if there are things
that you can do together not just giving
her
homework assignments
that increase self-awareness that could
be somatic self-awareness it could be
getting better at applying things like
the 80 20 principle to career so it
might be a workshop along those lines
anything that
helps to facilitate the habit of turning
the eye inward
and asking questions i think will also
not just lead to self-development but be
self-development in and of itself so
those are a few of my
thoughts on that which is not an easy
situation it's not always an easy
situation
but i do think there are many options in
between the two polar extremes that you
indicated and i do not think those two
are mutually exclusive i think you can
incorporate
both all right let me take a look at
some live questions here folks
claudia do you have any self-discipline
advice for adhd folks
who have already tried everything i'm a
german teacher by the way
well it's
to meet you and
i would say
and you can find quite a bit written on
this
you could see
examples
from bj fogg
who
maybe still is but certainly was
teaching at stanford for a long time and
looking at behavioral modification you
could look at atomic habits you could
also look at the four hour chef which
talks about this at some length and the
four-hour body and that is using
accountability and incentives
right so if you want to make a change
having accountability in place in the
form of both people
and
rewards and or punishments punishments
work really well say financial
punishment where if you don't do a b and
c
then
you
will in advance provide 100 euros to a
close friend who will donate it to
your least favorite non-profit the one
you would not want to be associated with
in your name for instance these types of
mechanisms
and setting these types of conditions
can be very very effective so
certainly even though i appreciate the
question i don't believe that any of us
have already tried everything
and i would suggest
looking at not methods of convincing
yourself
but the setting of incentives such that
it
is
compelling sufficiently compelling for
you to change the behaviors that you
want to change
and
both the 4-hour body and the 4-hour chef
get into this in quite a bit of detail
but there are other examples bj fogg and
then james clear with atomic habits
and also charles duhigg
is another one who has written a lot on
habit d-u-h-i-g-g
and
i find a lot of what
he has presented to be
extremely interesting
all right let's see let's see what else
we got
so timer
how do you plan such that emotionally
tough moments aren't destabilizing and
then the examples of breakups death of
family members etc
and
my answer to this is there are
certainly tools and philosophies and
frameworks like stoicism that can help
you weather some of these storms
but in some ways i find the most freeing
way to think about this
to
not
set the expectation and the pressure
that you can prevent these things from
being destabilizing
expect them to be destabilizing and
accept that you are
human and that billions of people
feel somewhat temporarily destabilized
by these things and that it's okay
there is a book
that i i found very helpful and i do
think the written version is different
from the audiobook for some reason
and you can skip around it found me at
the right time by bruce tift tift called
already free
which
really
covers a lot of this
oliver berkman
in his book also talks about this quite
a bit that
you feel and produce manufacture
stress for instance when
you ask yourself how can i
best handle all of my inbound which
might be hundreds or thousands of
different messages
whereas on some level if you accept that
as impossible
you can finally begin to make at least
psychological or psycho-emotional
headway so i would just say
that
expecting it to be tough
and possibly destabilizing
could be the first salve that you apply
and in fact even if you read the moral
letters to leukeleus
or other examples of writing from famous
stoics the most famous seneca the
younger etc
[ __ ] was hard bad things happen and
it's i think valuable to strive towards
certain ideals and to follow certain
principles and philosophies but i think
accepting
your human experience and validating it
by
not setting
the expectation that you will be able to
avoid these emotions may be freeing in
some capacity
i see a lot of questions about things
i've changed my mind about in the last
12 months
you know i'm having i'm having trouble
coming up with something immediate but i
will say that certainly
watching the markets for the last few
months has just reinforced
as some of the most famous and
venerated names of the last few years
have been obliterated
in terms of hedge fund managers and
other types of investors just wiped off
the face of the planet financially even
though you know gathering their
two percent management fee every year
they're perfectly fine so no one has to
cry any tears for the hedge fund
managers they'll be okay
but
having seen the complete
like supernova of capital destruction
it's just become all the more clear to
me that basically
no one knows
what they're doing or put a different
way that may be too strong that everyone
is making it up as they go along and we
shouldn't convince
as i heard stanley druckenmiller say
once we should not convince a bull
market with being a genius
those are two
very very very different things
and
and on one hand that's depressing
or
unfortunate because it'd be nice to
think if i just find the right expert
i'll be able to
figure out my finances invest and always
make money and this than the other thing
but when you talk to someone like morgan
household you realize whatever your
favorite asset class is at some point
it's going to go down by 70 percent that
could be next year it could be
next week it could be five years from
now but eventually you're going to get
punched in the face extremely hard by
these macro trends
so what i'm saying is on one hand it'd
be nice to think that if you just find
the right expert everything would be
solved but it's also freeing when you
realize even the people who are
supposedly the best at this a lot of
them
happen to just be riding
as they might say secular tailwinds and
sort of floating atop a bubble before it
all burst and they were just trying to
rake in as much cash as possible before
that happened
and
i find that kind of reassuring if that
if that makes any sense right it's kind
of like watching reality tv and you're
like wow like i complain about my life a
lot but
as chris bosh said on this podcast
if if you got a whole table of people
together and they all put their problems
on the table you might pick up your
problems right back and keep them for
yourself
that when you watch reality tv and
you're like wow these people are a mess
and you feel better about your own
situation
it should be
humbling collectively
and certainly individually but just to
realize that even the best
in the world or people who are
considered that
are getting their faces ripped off there
are some examples of exceptions right
but
i find that to be very top of mind for
me at the moment so i i've perhaps
changed my mind on how i view very
specific investors
somewhat although
again these investors generally if
they're really smart figure out ways to
win even if they lose so
one could say they haven't really
lost the game per se they just chose the
right game to begin with for more on
that i recommend reading
more money than god by
sebastian maliby i believe it is
yep sebastian maliby who also has a very
good book on venture capital more
recently i believe it's called the power
law
so that's something that comes to mind
and every
day every week
i am certainly finding more
examples of strongly held emotional
positions or
anger-based biases that i have that
are more reflective of my upbringing and
environment than any objective truth in
the situations that seem to catalyze
them
certainly that's something i'm also
paying a lot of attention to so those
are
those are just a few thoughts in
response
to that question
okay
all right guys got a few more minutes
i'm gonna see
what else we have this question uh
nurdain do i still do slow carb yes i do
still do slow carb and i am currently
following slow carb
that is the slow carb diet for those who
are not familiar if you search how to
lose 100 pounds on the slow carb diet
you will see a number of case studies
that are
i think very impressive and lay out the
basics of the diet it is not complicated
all right
let me take
a look here
see what else we have all right this is
a question from
matt
how do i ask for money as a green beret
i got good at military process for
funding training equipment and special
projects now i'm building a solar panel
factory in south texas
and the civilian world of funding is a
new animal for me as an investor what
inspires you to ultimately invest and
work with a particular startup
let me respond to this
with a few thoughts and i'm going to
keep it simple so the first is
there's an out of print book
not all of it is great advice but it
will be
i think helpful food for thought and
that is guerrilla financing there's a
book called guerrilla financing
which
covers alternative modes of financing
and i recommend this because
most of the
startups and small businesses that get a
lot of media attention are
venture-backed startups they are taking
money from venture capitalists
and angel investors
like me
and hoping for a 10x or 100x return
on that money to their investors and
certainly to themselves and their
employees
that model does not work for most things
so
for instance in this example of a solar
panel factory that may be a very
unappealing
and
irrational
place to focus in in that particular
startup
venture capital market and there are
other options right you have things like
invoice factoring you have certainly
let's just consider it traditional debt
you have different ways to secure that
debt
and
i think that it is it is probably a good
idea to broaden the horizon
of awareness related to
alternative funding
mechanisms and approaches so guerrilla
financing would be one
you can also find early investment decks
these are pitches so it could be 10
slides it could be 20 it could be five
four
startups and companies that have done
really well so you could look at
any number of examples the earliest
examples of decks are available for a
lot of the
unicorns and decacorns and now
successful publicly traded tech
companies
and you can find those online if you
just search
such and such company early deck
early investment pitch you will be able
to find a lot of those
and
those are probably the two first
recommendations i would make if you
really want to learn about venture
capital there are some good books out
there brad feld
is a very good investor who has an
entire book about
different ways to structure and evaluate
and
contract venture capital investments
but i would say before you go barking up
that tree and do a really deep dive on
venture capital i would get a broader
understanding of the many different
vehicles and approaches you can take for
financing
and look at small businesses not just
venture-backed startups
and best of luck good luck
all right
next question
why did you stop asking your guests who
they think is successful and why this
was always my favorite question on the
podcast hearing successful people define
success has helped rewire my own
thinking around success just as reading
four hour work week changed my entire
perspective around time
as an aside thank you for all you do
your work has improved my life
immeasurably
well thank you for the question ryan and
the kind words
i stopped asking
the question
who do you think
of when i say the word successful and
why
for a few reasons
what i found is first if i didn't
disqualify certain types of answers i
tended to get the same answers over and
over and over and over again so i would
get richard branson i would get elon
musk i would get bill gates
the
the names you might expect from the tech
titan pantheon
of sorts
that's the first issue the second is
on a large podcast some people feel as
though if they don't name their parents
they aren't fulfilling their filial
piety so they will say my mom or my dad
or my mom and dad and it is
not
generally a real answer sometimes it is
but generally that is a
a political
answer not an honest answer and i tend
to agree with derek sivers because i ask
derek sivers i highly recommend all my
conversations with derek he is fantastic
he's actually very similar in
constitution in some ways to kevin kelly
i asked derek sivers this question he
said well
i can't really answer that question
without
knowing the motivations and goals of the
person i might name so he said you know
i might be tempted to say richard
branson but if richard branson
has set out to
live a life of peace and quiet and
tranquility and to slow down then his
life is potentially a total failure if
he's
feeling compelled to constantly create
new companies and so on so it's it's
very hard at surface level to judge
who is successful without understanding
their motivations and priorities and so
on now had richard branson on the
podcast also i think
that
i think that he is certainly
following his priorities and his inner
compass to the best
of my ability to tell but the point
still remains it's difficult to discern
and so
what
derek said was really you should ask
when i say the word successful who is
the third person that you think of
because that will but first it'll be
elon musk or jeff bezos or whatever
and in a second it'll be
my parents
and then the third answer will be when
you finally get to some degree of of
truth that is
uh non-consensus and non-political so
given all of that
and the maybe impracticality of asking
someone so when you hear the word
successful who's the third person who
comes to mind
explaining the question would take just
as much time as them answering it i
dropped that from my usual rotation but
i'll consider adding it back in but but
it it was
given some thought it was not accidental
that that got removed from the rotation
okay let me take a look at just a few
last questions and then i'm going to hop
off guys
and uh we will
go from there all right bear with me let
me look at this
am i planning to do my drunk dial shows
again from ernestus
no time soon uh those were fun but i've
i've cut back substantially on alcohol
consumption not because i think it's a
bad thing i still drink alcohol i had a
glass of wine last night
but
i have found that as i get older
the penalty i pay
for
getting properly drunk let's just i'm
not
blackout drunk but let's just say three
or four drinks
is very high it ends up affecting not
just the next day but probably two days
subsequent so i'm just i i'm
increasingly unwilling to pay that tax
all right let's see let me see what we
got here
okay guys i'm just looking at a few i'm
trying to find a good one to end on
let me take a look
reida any tips for someone who wants to
start a podcast
being an introvert so
starting a podcast if you're an
introvert i consider myself an introvert
i am recharged
by myself or in very small groups say
dinner with one to three people and i'm
depleted by large groups so
if you are saying
i am an introvert but people tell me i
should start a podcast what should i do
my answer is don't start a podcast
if you are asking
i am an introvert as i just defined it
and you could also define that as being
highly sensitive to stimuli
so i don't like being in loud
restaurants i don't like being in places
where
there's a high volume on any sense could
be bright lights
i don't enjoy that at all i find it
depleting
ask yourself as an introvert am i
nourished or depleted by one-on-one
conversations if the answer is depleted
don't do a podcast if the answer is
nourished then you can very easily do a
podcast which is why i prefer
having generally
say in the podcast with the long-form
interviews one-on-one conversations that
i can then broadcast to millions of
people that is my ideal i also enjoy
doing these q and a's but it's basically
me looking at scrolling text and my own
bald head on a webcam so it's
kind of like giving myself some stuart
smally affirmations in the mirror in the
morning has has some effect along those
lines
all right let me look at try to find a
few more guys
okay anand one person i would interview
any day or every day
there are quite a few actually i think
kevin kelly would be on that list
noah feldman who's been on this podcast
would be on that list
kevin rose
probably another who would be on that
list
and i'm sure i could come up with more
okay
question if i had to recommend just one
of my books to a random person i met on
the street it'd be
it'd be a funny
exchange for sure excuse me hi my name
is tim ferriss i'd like to recommend one
of my books
uh have a good day sir
but
which one would it be and why it would
be tools of titans i think that is just
the largest funnel in the sense that it
will appeal to the highest percentage of
people i could give it to
there's something in that book for
everyone i think so it would be tools of
titans
all right
request for larry david on the podcast
absolutely would love to have larry
david on
i was hoping to have bob einstein on i
was very sad that he passed before i had
the chance
all right
tracy am i still using evernote every
day yes i use evernote almost every day
and you know i i find the ui fine and
it's easy enough to use i'm a creature
of habit so i have used it forever at
some point i might make a transition i
think rome research is very interesting
and there are a handful of others but at
this point yes i still use evernote
here's a question i'll end on this one
so this is from cafeina that's funny
what is on my billboard so i'm actually
going to steal an answer
from a podcast guest whose name
i invoked earlier in this conversation
dr bj miller the hospice care physician
who has helped thousands of people to
die
and he in turn got this from some bumper
sticker i asked him where he found it
and i thought it was hilarious i was
expecting this really
profound nuance story he said no i think
i saw it on a bumper sticker and the
answer is
very present for me right now and that
is don't believe everything that you
think
right so this is a variation on
don't believe everything you read but i
really think
scrutinizing our thoughts
and beliefs which are the thoughts we
take to be true
is increasingly it always has been
important but it is increasingly
important in a world that is designed
mostly enabled by tech platforms and
social media to polarize the [ __ ] out of
you and to reward you for making your
viewpoints more and more extreme and
simplified
don't believe everything that you think
and i would recommend for people who
want to explore
how you might do that in a structured
way you can you can look at the work by
byron katie and there are worksheets you
can download for free that allow you to
scrutinize some of your beliefs and
thoughts
and i and many of my podcast guests have
found those worksheets to be incredibly
helpful
and on that
i am going to see what i can do about
exercise and some dinner
and
i very much appreciate everybody being
here thank you for tuning in
hopefully this was helpful in some
capacity i'm running a little low today
on battery charge so i hope it was
coherent at least portions of it were
coherent thank you for all the questions
both the submitted questions
that were sent ahead of time as well as
the live questions
and i really deeply appreciate all of
you
it is uh
a small miracle that i'm able to do this
type of thing
for a living as my job
and
i am incredibly thankful incredibly
grateful every day that i get to
have the conversations i get to have and
to hopefully
share
whatever
things i have learned in any small way
after the many many experiments that i
subject me and
my life to so it is really an honor to
interact with all of you and
have a wonderful evening wherever you
may be if you're listening to this in
the morning good morning have a
wonderful morning or afternoon have a
wonderful day as it may be and
everything that has been discussed will
be put into the show notes later if this
is broadcast on the podcast team dot
blog slash podcast
and until next time
just be a little bit kinder than you
think is necessary when you walk out
that door
if everyone is an [ __ ] just remember
you are probably the [ __ ] so it'd be
a good time to remember that billboard
don't believe everything that you think
scrutinize those thoughts they can be
pretty squirrely
and thank you all for tuning in
you